[Musik]
da immer noch es ist eigentlich vom fond
aus temax tochter von toyota und darum
hans zimmer mit dem dbb-team büro und ja
jetzt das leere davoser aber wie oft und
ist eigentlich guter dinge dass sich
liebelt da ist wohin geht ein mann der
von seiner frau physische und psychische
prügel einstecken muss und was macht er
wenn auch noch ein kind im spiel ist
dass männer und väter haus in bern ist
ein letzter zufluchtsort denn auch
sebastian aufgesucht hat die männer und
der ort müssen zum schutz anonym bleiben
die namen sind erfunden die stimmen nach
gesprochen
die geschichten aber könnten realer
nicht sein
dies ist ein film der die üblichen
geschlechterrollen ins wanken bringt
dass männer und väter haus wird von
einer frau geleitet
sie erhält täglich ein blick in den
abgrund des nach wie vor vorhandenen
geschlechter grabens es kommen vor allem
männer her die nicht verstandene nicht
gesehen werden
sie werden nicht verstanden werden nicht
gesehen sie werden und sofern ich
gesehen sondern nur als zehnter
sie werden nicht verstanden wenn sie
europa sind dass sie bedürfnisse haben
dienen auch gerecht werden müsse sie
werden nicht gesehen als väter
sie werden nicht gesehen dass sie als
väter gleich behandelt werden sollten es
mütter und dass man ihnen gegenüber ohne
vorderteile herangeht war sich merkel in
unserer gesellschaft ist dass jedermann
ein potenzieller täter ist ja und das
stimmt mich es nicht gerecht
es ist nicht gerecht männer sind nicht
potenzielle täter ihr sinn für
gleichberechtigung hat sie angestachelt
aufgewachsen als angehörige einer
deutschen minderheit in rumänien hat die
ausgrenzung auch selber erfahren
ich bin jemand der gerne etwas neues
aufbauen oder auch die in ihrer arbeit
leistet und die thematik ist mir
irgendwie nah gewesen aber ich hätte
genauso etwas für frauen gemacht oder
für kinder oder sogar so wie man also
das ging jetzt nicht speziell für männer
was zu machen habe ich habe einfach
gemerkt es ist der lücke im system
da gibt es leute die durch die laster
des systems fallen was noch nicht
abgedeckt ist und nach der arbeit zum
übernachten oder ganze tage oder wochen
die männer sind hier in ihrer not
willkommen
als ausgebildeter systemische beraterin
wie sieglinde themen das ganze system
erkennen und nicht nur symptome bekannt
werth war hier schon mehrmals zu gast
er kommt mittlerweile lieber direkt ins
männerhaus als dass er noch einmal zur
polizei gehst du bist gar nicht ernst
genommen ja sie hat ca du wirst es
klappt oder es für okra so baut oder zu
töten würde zur durch die 2 womit jedes
interview wurde das protokoll machen
einmal was ich von der frau laut löscher
nach dem motto das würde die mit
lackierten und und du bist meine clinton
es ist es tabu thema und wenn der
teragate der bestands einfach ganz
einfach ist sehr sehr niedrig und sehr
niedrige niveau gehabt dort geschlagen
werden glaube ich würde das gerne monat
uhr sie hat die kraft nicht um mord
nicht wert fühlte sich von den behörden
nicht ernst genommen er opfer von gewalt
musste sich verteidigen und
rechtfertigen
vor einem jahr hatte bat einen
hirnschlag seither schlager seine frau
mit allen möglichen gegenständen immer
wieder auf dieselbe stelle große
stimmungsschwankungen für die es kein
anständiges ventil gibt seien der grund
die gewalt nimmt kein ende das fleisch
wie flasche auf den kopf geschlagen
heftige sache oder sie einfach ganz
gezielt mir irgendwo einfach grübeln
behinderung oder vision
ich bringe dich um oder einfach die
jungs bringen
das sehr genau weiß wo sie muss aber
schlau oder und trotzdem trennt sich
bert nicht da ist die angst bei einer
trennung finanziell zugrunde zu gehen
aber auch das wissen um die eigenen
unzulänglichkeiten und dass er schneller
als täter abgestempelt wird wenn er
handgreiflich wird und nicht zuletzt
findet in die hoffnung dass es doch
irgendwann besser werden könnte wer weiß
zeitweise weder aus noch ein du immer
wieder für riegler als jahren jene die
nicht was man da sicher sie ersten mal
sieht sich der mann selber nicht gern
und apfel
das heißt das opfer bild des mangels
auch bei den männern die hier kommen und
sorgt für sie bezeichnen sich nicht
gerne so weil der mann ist kein opfer
der mann hätte stark dass dieses
männerbild ist einfach vorhanden und und
wenn ein mann sich als opfer bezeichnet
bezeichnete sich automatisch als
versorger und wer möchte sich schon als
versager bezeichnet und sie halten die
gewalt der frauen einfach aus sie halten
sie einfach was sie sagen ich kann das
ertragen was sie weniger ertragen können
und was sie oft gar nicht sehen weil das
sehr schleichend ist und weil sie es gar
nicht als gewalt bezeichnet werden das
ist die psychische gewalt die ganze
kontrolle die beschimpfungen das mobbing
gegenüber den kindern ging die
eifersucht die die manchmal dimensionen
annimmt das kann man sich normal gar
nicht vorstellen
und das alles das ist ja das ist für sie
sehr sehr schwierig das ist sehr
schwierig der stolz hat auch sebastian
lange davon abgehalten hilfe zu holen
die körperlichen verletzungen heilen
auch wenn in seinem fall das handgelenk
noch operiert werden muss aber der
schmerz von der drei monate alten
tochter getrennt zu sein sitzt tief nun
ist der bei sieglinde klemmen und kämpft
darum seine tochter ins haus nehmen zu
können
nachdem die vaterschaft mit einem test
geklärt werden musste kann er endlich
mit der casp weiter schon
er kann einen vorfall schildern bei dem
das kindeswohl gefährdet war
die hat noch extra ob sie rät daher ob
sie nochmal verschrotten ist das wo sie
mich fragen ob sie die revision bringe
nichts wenn du das machst dann wird im
eigenen labels richie und kvh dann hat
sie mir aufgezeigt die kritik rührt
wenn ich nur proxy wenn dann versionen
politik vor da waren ja eigentlich
abgeschaltet dass sich die frau
hier wird andere trotzdem dass ich ihre
letzte chance gehabt und nur zwei bis
drei allerletzte chance geht nicht der
vorlage dass sie eigentlich medikaments
wieder nimmt also dann die depressiv
aber sie lang abgesetzt hat und nimmer
knallt ob und wie die behörden handeln
ist zu diesem zeitpunkt noch offen
wenn ein mann quasi die bessere mutter
ist dann macht das manchmal schwer zu
verstehen sein ja massiv ist sprach die
werke spiel fang der richtige stil und
denkt jetzt erstmals einfache erklärung
sagte wir hoffen einfach dass ich meine
tochter so schnell wie möglich wieder
gesehen
es ist einfach bis wo fällt man fühlt
sich dem volk komme man fragt sich
hundertmal am tag muss sie jetzt
angeordnet weil sich immer wieder
feststelle ist und ich drücke es jetzt
wirklich ein bisschen über spätesten
provokativ aus was ich immer wieder
feststelle ist eine mentalität die in
der gesellschaft herrscht augen helfer
system wo man davon ausgeht die mutter
ist gut fürs kind und der vater ist
optional
und das ist vor allem da wo die frauen
auch selber wieder selber sehr belastet
sind mit mit eigenen
persönlichen probleme mit
psychologischen probleme mit vielleicht
auch trauma das die dahinter stecken die
dazu geführt haben
die entdeckt sind die behandelt werden
oder die sogar noch nicht behandelt
werden sondern wirklich abgeklärt werden
müssen
während die alleingelassenen suchen im
männer und väter haus oft einen letzten
hoffnungsschimmer
der nächste gast auf zeit ist david mit
seinen beiden kindern
die behörden hätten bei seiner situation
nicht genau hingeschaut die probleme der
frau klein geredet bis er sich selber
zum handeln gezwungen sah ich hoffe auf
weitere frau und vivendi albert vier
männer eine frau ohne problem ist ein
buch reichau forschungsrat dazu ich weiß
sowieso weg hin zum fertigmachen
wow wow jetzt glaube ich noch bringen so
schnell
und türe zumachen die ohren zumachen
nicht fest die einzige lösung das was
immer gesagt hat ist einfach man muss
aber man muss sich scheiden man muss gar
als vater und mich in diesem zustand
ruckler dann ist da niemand mehr da und
das ist ja die luft weg es liegt mir im
richtigen leben richtig ohne und die
kinder sind noch zu klein als dass sie
die situation entsprechend einschätzen
können
aber auch die erwachsenen sind in ihrem
kampf hilflos es dreht sich immer wieder
im kreis
meist ist die rede von zwei
persönlichkeitsstörungen die sich nur
schwer bis gar nicht dingfest machen
lassen nazismus und borderline großes
heile welt alles schön und gut aber dann
sobald türen zu sind am anfang zu druck
und sich also dass ich das audio
mitgemacht haben
damit bleibt der bww bringen
was nach ist das nämlich einig sind
merkt an ich trage nie groß machen
ich bin ja hoffen auf das hat alles noch
viel schlimmer gemacht und dann in
letzter zeit ist einfach wegnehmen so
aussieht dass ich meinen vertrag standen
und dort wartet historikers und ich da
auch ein kind beruhigen
die mutter sei überfordert hätte auch
schon therapie in anspruch genommen und
dann die ultimativen druckmittel mit dem
frau der man angst einjagt
und am anfang ist sexy dass er sich das
auto am rosenhain kennt das ist echt
eine bisher autor und ist natürlich der
klassiker neben dem kind wegzunehmen und
das jahrzehnt das war zu stark taxi das
war nicht machen blieb das akzeptieren
dass man kennt und dann das kind nominal
2 woche zwei tage und das ist die größte
angst überhaupt dass ich mich in mir
gesehen
es geht den kindern hier in männer und
väter haus den umständen entsprechend
gut sieglinde erklimmen ist auf abruf da
wenn man sie braucht
im moment ist zeichnen mit den kindern
gefragt da ich es dass du machst es
immer so schön bunt die emissionen ja
nicht unbedingt das ist der nächste fall
kommt und dann geht's weiter
klar man schließt ins herz aber
vermessen ist ist glaubt wer die falsche
ort ja das ist eine momentane beziehung
die wichtig ist die auf stabilität gebe
sollte dieser schwierigen situation
und dann ist wichtig auch das mal wieder
loslassen kann von beiden seiten ich bin
nicht eine bezugsperson die in ihrem
leben bleiben wird und darauf muss man
auch immer ein bisschen achten zeit für
sentimentalität bleibt nicht immer ein
anderer gast ist verschwunden wert der
von seiner frau mit allem möglichen
geschlagen wurde ist weg jetzt grund
jan immer wieder probiert ihn zu
erreichen aber wir hätten immer
geantwortet und das ist ein bisschen
schwierig zu beweisen warum er sich
nicht meldet
er ist ja wiederkommen wenn er wieder
hilfe braucht aber momentan ist die
situation dass ich das zimmer freenet
halten kann weil ich ja immer wieder
bedarf hat sind jetzt auch die halle
drüben deponiert er sorge wie soll ich
ihnen sage man weiß ja nicht wie es
ihnen geht und was die motivation ist
und und überhaupt aber ja wir nehmen es
wie sich die situation ändern
drei monate nach diesen dreharbeiten
erfahren wir dass bert versucht hat sich
das leben zu nehmen habe die
ungerechtigkeit nicht mehr ertragen sagt
er
zudem sei seinen aggressionspotenzial
gestiegen
der alltag von sieglinde erklimmen ist
nicht einfach
während die drei frauenhäuser im kanton
bern
gesamthaft über drei millionen vom
sozialamt erhalten muss das männerhaus
ohne staatliches geld auskommen mit
einem jährlichen budget von knapp 100
zehntausend franken
zum größten teil durch gönner und
stiftungen finanziert muss sorgsam
gehaushaltet werden
ich investiere dann meine kraft lieber
darin hier die arbeit zu leisten für die
männer die in not sind und dann über
einzelfallhilfen stiftungen und diese
kosten erstattet zu kriegen obwohl es ja
schon nicht mehr aufwand ist dass männer
und väter haus gehört zum verein
zwischenhalt der in aarau luzern und
bern drei häuser betreibt der aufbau war
zeitweise eine ein frau show sieben tage
die woche für alles und jeden da zu sein
das geht gut das macht und es ist licht
man darf nicht aufgehen so das motto von
sieglinde klima staatlich wird das
männerhaus nicht unterstützt und deshalb
fehlt auch die offizielle kontrolle was
wiederum nahrung für vorurteile und
kritik bietet und dass ein mann ein
opfer ist scheint schwere zu beweisen
und zu akzeptieren zu sein bei denen die
zu mir eigentlich als opfer kommen
passiert es immer wieder dass sie nicht
anerkannt werden weil der opferberatung
sagt schnell ja schon klar dass kennt
gegenseitig sein und da kommt er mit uns
als ob das schutzgesetz weil es nicht
genau nachweisen kann und psychische
gewalt nachzuweisen ist dann sowieso
schwierig wenn man nicht gerade mit mit
dem messer im rücken kommt oder mit dem
gebrochenen arm oder mit dem fahrrad was
wirklich sehr sehr übersichtlich ist und
nachvollziehbar wie bei sebastian ihm
wurde seine kleine tochter von der kespa
zugesprochen
für den moment ist die welt wieder in
ordnung
wie geht's
ja solar jetzt endlich wieder verbunden
damit dann immer wieder gesagt worden
ist dass man sie nie mehr wird gesehen
und aus und an harrison happy nur
sieglinde sei als einzige richtige
unterstützung geblieben sonst habe
sebastian sein ganzes umfeld verloren
die kindesmutter versuche ihn zu
isolieren und wo es nur geht schlecht zu
machen
er hat in dieser zeit auch wenn es
schwer war immer das ziel vor augen für
seine tochter ein guter vater zu sein es
ist vor allem ein super provisorische
lösung momentan der entscheid foto
christ oder durch momentan noch nicht
fix was sebastian alles durchmachen muss
passt nicht in einen film
es ist ein schier endlos scheinender
kampf bei dem das männliche geschlecht
ein nachteil zu sein scheint wenn das
für sie schwer zu verdauen ist immer
wieder und und auch sie verzweifeln ist
und und wieder ein rückschlag ist das
kann ich mit ihnen verarbeiten und da
kann ich sie auch unterstützen und da
kann ich ihnen auch helfen das wieder
anzunehmen und und daraus wieder eine
perspektive zu entwickeln und sagen okay
die tat ist sogar bei andere gedauert
wir schauen weiter das kann nicht gut ja
aber wenn wir nicht dann selber merke
die ignoranz der behörden und so das ist
dann manchmal schon schwierig wie im
fall von david er ist am aufräumen
seine beiden kinder sind nicht mehr hier
bei einem begleiteten besuch hat die
frau die kinder einfach mitgenommen
obwohl es anders abgemacht war und das
ist dank sie hierzu einfach magnum ohne
probleme jetzt sind sie immer geschützt
wolfsburger wie man die verbindung hält
da können einem sache doch ob seine
schätze was jetzt genau ist so ganz ohne
was machen was sie mit drin
die die väter nehme ja die kinder nicht
zum spaß mit hierher sondern sie nehmen
sich ja hierher weil sie in schutz
bringen weil sie sich sorgen machen
und wenn sie dann nicht gehört werden
nicht ernst genommen werden und solche
situationen entstehen
und er merkt es hilft ihnen immer
unternehmer glaubt das ist das niemand
geglaubt haben
verzweiflung trauer wut drei gefühle mit
denen man hier leben muss man kann ja
auch vernünftig getrennt voneinander in
anführungsstrichen zusammensitzen um zu
schauen welche lösungen es gibt dass
beide da rauskommen
10 das buch zu nutzen das braucht
einerseits vernunft und andererseits
brauche das system das gerecht hinschaut
und nicht mit vorurteilen oder mit
vorverurteilung oder stigmatisierung
es gibt sie die geschichten bei denen
die männer die vermeintlichen frauen
sind und gegen die klassischen
geschlechterrollen ankämpfen müssen
jetzt über dieses bett liegt die
dunkelziffer wie oft männer unter gewalt
leiden sei wahrscheinlich hoch hört man
hinter vorgehaltener hand auch bei den
entsprechenden behörden dass hier eine
männliche minderheit ihre sicht
schildern konnte schmälert in keiner
weise das leid dass frauen erfahren
trotzdem ist es wohl angezeigt die
gängigen klischees zu überprüfen und
frauen oder männer bilder zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]